[Applause]
are you surprised are you surprised
Bruce Willis yes yeah I knew he would be
I mean even though I went over
everything yesterday I knew he'd forget
[Laughter]
so for those of you who don't know me
I'm Demi Moore I was married to Bruce
Willis for the first three die hard
movies which makes sense because the
last two sucked after all these years I
have to say you know what you look good
I mean you still look the same
from the eyebrows up but we had some
great times together I mean we share it
a lot
I had three beautiful amazing children
four if you count Bruce and then there's
the dogs and Ashton so it's like six but
you know I mean and of course you know
like we did argue over the kids names
and in the end Bruce won that's how they
got stuck with Willis I have to say our
daughters are incredibly well adjusted
considering two of them are half Bruce
Willis he's a great father I mean
seriously I mean every Christmas right
after he would have the girls go make
him his special coffee with medicine I
mean he would come down the chimney and
the wife beater t-shirt waving that gun
thing yippee-ki-yay
and then I mean that's what he's always
called them and they get
they just love his taglines I mean but
what you might not know Bruce is super I
mean really generous I mean what our
daughter rumor was a baby and it was his
turn to change the diaper in the middle
of the night he'd leaned over and
whispered eat I'll give you $1,000 right
now if you changed that diaper of course
I wouldn't do it because well the lawyer
said don't worry we'll take care of it
we'll get it in the end and scout scout
asked me not to say anything but just
last week he offered her $1,000 to
change his diaper I mean some things
never change
they don't I mean we were married let's
see
almost 12 years and that's like 84 in
Bruce Willis years but I was there for
some special moments like groundbreaking
I mean Bruce was he got his career
breaking moment and pulp fiction yeah I
mean it was it's even really odd at the
time
I mean he's big action star like doing a
little indie film but Bruce went over to
Harvey Weinstein's hotel and I don't
know he came back swinging that ball gag
and miss any said I got the part
I mean it's plenty of the things we do
for a part like I know that I have died
and cut and styled my hair and I can
tell you how a million ways but not
Bruce I mean that's his real hair and
ladies let me tell you the carpets match
the drapes he's bald down there I'm just
saying whichever place you look it looks
like a dick you know after our divorce
he said that he considered the end of
our marriage his biggest failure but
Bruce don't be so hard on yourself
you have had much bigger failures I mean
Planet Hollywood Hudson Hawk striking
distance come on
campaigning for Michael Dukakis I mean
turning down Clooney's role in Ocean's
eleven to focus on playing the harmonica
I mean I mean I could go on but they
said it's a a two-hour show so but you
know what I look back over all the years
that we've had together we certainly had
our ups and downs but I have to say
those were some of the best times of my
life I just look at our marriage like
the sixth sense you were dead the whole
time
all kidding aside really all kidding
aside I'm really honored to be here you
are someone I truly care about you will
always have a special place in my heart
I'm so grateful that you're in my life
and our children's lives and no matter
what you will always be family you've
been a great friend a great father and
easily one of my top three husbands
[Applause]
[Music]